[Music]
the screen ducky show with how Rudnick
sup noobs
guys I gotta admit I almost didn't do
this episode cuz I'm sick I have honey
booboo fever these lovable fat
hillbillies have taken hold of my heart
the same way cholesterol has taken hold
of their I love talking honey booboo
with my pals for example I was kickin it
with my good buddies and stars of the
awesome new comedy Seven Psychopaths Sam
Rockwell Christopher Walken and Colin
Farrell
I call him SIA because he's my bf and I
couldn't help but give here comes honey
boo boo
the cast of Psychopaths it truly
deserves guys I love the movie I want
everybody to see this I like to tie the
movie into the greatest Psychopaths in
American pop culture today honey boo boo
child maybe we could turn this into a
honey boo boo motion picture if you
wouldn't mind reading honey boo boo and
that Chris if you would read mama please
and I'll direct action the deer are not
migrating like they should be and
nobody's hit a deer with their car been
a while since I've done that at roadkill
in my belly so I mean you know we try to
make other kinds of foods like you know
scary I want butter sketchy and ketchup
it's an old family recipe don't tell
nobody moody move you put a little bit
of butter with the ketchup melted in the
microwave that's pretty good Oh
[Music]
is it yes yes mom they said it was
disgusting well tell them not to eat it
next time I'm just playing they said it
it's the bone cuz I made it that's why
it's the bomb Oh Bravo gentlemen I
wouldn't I wouldn't change a thing
having another circulated in a certain
walk to this this material has of such
great actors
Thanks look Reid chubbs oh truck you
would be chubbs yeah and if you would be
mama again Oh mr. burns I failed it I
feel sad feel really big killer action
here comes honey boo boo child scene 2
how much weight are you gonna lose about
20 up honey what are you gonna start
tomorrow if you follow 12 to 15 time of
day you can lose a lot of weight so I'll
take out gonna lose a lot of weight
because I've gotta fought a lot there
are some brokedown people out there
please women that are up full up to a
size not all that back jiggle jag Allah
is not beautiful wow these are words
thank you you know it's a little too
hard you gentlemen nailed it and I feel
like this is the perfect tool to help
get you got it done I'm gonna get asses
in the seats get them in I was naked oh
yeah get outside the box that's the best
interview all day right yeah yeah that's
a lot of fun hey it's just me your
sketti sound uh delicious
I got try some we got the butter we took
a bunch of little patties of butter and
melted them in the microwave so that's
what you see here the melty butter I'm
gonna do what mama do oh wow oh yeah I'm
mixing the butter and ketchup together
and the butter start to congeal over oh
boy rethinking this I wish you could
smell the tomato whoa we mix it up real
good now it's time to pour it on sketti
it actually looks a little like a like a
nice marinara far from it pretty and far
from it this is a lot of ketchup and a
lot of butter this is for you honey boo
boo
ooh carrot really good really good guys
so what you're doing here comes honey
boo boo can watch the Christopher Walken
honeymoon tell me I'm thinking walking
walk bear you guys you a new Lone Ranger
trailer it's so refreshing we should
joined up playing a weirdo I don't
forget to share subscribe be annoying
loser at work who sends links around all
day and if you already are that annoying
loser
thanks dude also big laugh chip email
for app tips a clean Dalton calm I'm al
Rudnick honey bye-bye - yep
check out our screen took his episode on
how not to get taken
where else I'll take you trust me I'm a
very particular set of skills thanks for
watching maybe we should friend each
other on Facebook the links in the
doobly-doo